[Music]
mechanisms of evolution
what is evolution evolution is the
development of life on earth
this is a process that began billions of
years ago and is still continuing to
this day
evolution tells us how it was possible
for the enormous diversity of life to
develop
it shows us how primitive protozoa could
become the millions of different species
that we see today
[Music]
evolution then is the answer to the
question that we have
all asked on seeing a dachshund and a
great dane together
how is it possible for ancestors to have
descendants
that look so very different to them
in answering this question we want to
focus on animals
excluding other forms of life such as
fungi and plants
the first question to ask is therefore
how can one animal develop into a whole
new species of animal
ah but just a quick question
what exactly is a species
a species is a community of animals that
is capable of producing offspring with
one another
with those offspring also being capable
of reproducing in turn
to understand this answer better we need
to take a closer look at the following
points
the uniqueness of living creatures
guaranteed through the excess production
of offspring
and heredity and as a second key point
selection let's begin with
uniqueness every creature that exists is
unique
and this is essential for evolution
the members of a species may strongly
resemble each other in appearance
however they all have slightly different
traits and characteristics
they may be a bit bigger fatter stronger
or
bolder than their fellow animals
so what is the reason for these
differences let's take a closer look at
a creature
every creature is made up of cells these
cells have a nucleus
the nucleus contains the chromosomes
and the chromosomes hold the dna
dna consists of different genes
and it's these genes that are life's
information carriers
[Music]
they contain instructions and orders for
the cells and determine the
characteristics and traits that living
creatures have
and it's precisely this dna that is
unique to every creature
it's slightly different from individual
to individual
which is why each has slightly different
characteristics
but how is the enormous range of dna
created
one key factor is the excess production
of offspring
in nature we can observe that creatures
generally produce far more offspring
than is necessary for the survival of
their species
with many offspring dying and early
death as a result
often there are even more offspring than
the environment in which they live is
able to support
this is one factor in increasing
diversity within a species
the more offspring that are produced the
more little differences occur
and this is what nature wants as many
little differences
as possible
[Music]
the second major cause of the uniqueness
of individuals occurs in heredity itself
by the way heredity means the passing on
of dna to offspring
[Music]
two very interesting factors come into
play in this process
recombination and mutation
recombination is the random mixing of
the dna of two creatures
when two creatures fall in love and mate
they recombine their genes
twice the first time they do this
separately
when they generate the gametes that is
sperm and
egg cells the gametes take half of the
genes and shuffle them
the second recombination occurs when a
male inseminates a female
the parents each provide fifty percent
of their dna
in other words fifty percent of their
unique traits and characteristics
these are then recombined or mixed and
the result is new offspring
these offspring have a random mix of the
dna and therefore the traits and
characteristics of their parents
this increases the diversity and
differences within a species
even further
but mutations are also important for
evolution
mutations are random changes in dna
these can also be described as copying
errors within the dna
triggered by toxins or other chemical
substances or by radiation
[Music]
a mutation exists when a part of the dna
is altered
these changes are often negative and may
result in illnesses such as cancer
however they may also have neutral or
positive effects
such as the blue eye color in humans
which is one such random mutation
in all cases a mutation has to affect a
gamete
that is a sperm or egg cell because only
the dna in the gametes is passed on to
the offspring
this is also the reason why we protect
our sexual organs during x-rays
whilst other parts of the body are not
at risk
in summary then in the heredity process
creatures pass on their characteristics
to their offspring in the form of dna
recombination and mutation change the
dna
so that each child looks different to
its siblings
and receives a random mix of the
characteristics of its parents
there's a key word here random
all of these processes are based on
chance
random recombination and mutations
result in individuals with random mixes
of traits and characteristics which in
turn mix these randomly
and pass them on
but how can so much be down to chance
when all living creatures are so
perfectly adapted to their environment
for example the stick insect the
hummingbird
and the frogfish
the answer is provided by the second key
point selection
each individual is subjected to a
process of natural selection
as we have learned each individual is
somewhat different to its fellows
and there is extensive variation within
a species
environmental influences have an effect
on living creatures
these so-called selection factors
include
predators parasites animals of the same
species
toxins changes in habitat or the climate
selection is a process that each
individual is subjected to
every creature has a unique mix of
traits and characteristics
this mix helps them to survive in their
environment
or not as the case may be
anyone with an unsuitable mix will be
selected from the environment
[Music]
those with the right mix survive and can
pass on their enhanced traits and
characteristics
[Music]
this is why diversity is so important
this is why creatures make so much
effort to produce offspring that are as
different as possible
they increase the likelihood that at
least one of their offspring passes
nature's selection process
they maximize their chances of survival
a good example of this can be seen in a
group of finches living on a remote
island they are some of the most famous
animals in the world of science
and are known as darwin finches after
their discoverer charles darwin
and this is the story of those finches a
few hundred years ago
a small group of finches was blown onto
the galapagos islands in the middle of
the pacific
probably by a big storm
[Music]
the finches found themselves in an
environment that was completely new to
them
a real finch paradise an abundance of
food
and no predators they reproduced rapidly
and numerously the islands were soon
heaving with finches
this meant that food supplies became
increasingly scarce
the finch paradise was threatened with
famine and finch friends became
competitors
this is when selection intervened their
individuality and small differences
in this case their slightly different
beaks meant that some of the birds were
able to avoid competing with their
fellow finches
the beaks of some of the finches were
more suitable for digging for worms
other finches were able to use their
beaks better for cracking seeds
the finches consequently sought out
ecological niches
in these niches they were safe from
excessive competition
they soon began to mate primarily with
other finches that used the same niche
over the course of many generations
these characteristics were enhanced
enabling the finches to exploit their
niches successfully
the differences between the worm diggers
and the seed crackers became so large
that they were no longer able to mate
with one another
different species emerged as a result
today there are 14 different species of
finch living on the galapagos islands
all of which are descended from the same
group of stranded finches
this is how new species are created by
evolution
through the interaction of unique
individuals the excess production of
offspring
recombination and mutation in heredity
and finally through selection
why is this so important it tells us
where the variety of life comes from
and why living creatures are so
perfectly adapted to their habitats
but it also affects us personally every
person is the result of three and a half
billion years of evolution
and that includes you your ancestors
fought and adapted in order to survive
this survival was an extremely uncertain
thing
[Music]
if we consider the fact that 99 of all
the species that have ever lived are
extinct
then you can consider yourself part of a
success story
[Music]
the dinosaurs have disappeared but you
are alive
watching this video because you're
incredibly special
just like all the other creatures that
exist today
irreproducible and unique in the
universe
[Music]
[Music]
you